[Music]
only on 8 tonight we're learning more
about an
incident that ended with a pickup truck
in a woman's apartment for the first
time we are actually seeing the
surveillance video of part of the
incident and we're learning more about
how the community is rallying to help
the woman
who lost nearly everything madison
kimbrough joining us live near valley
view in sahara where all of this
happened
madison yes the entire incident was
caught on camera from across the way at
this convenience store that you see here
the woman who was left physically
unharmed is trying to put things back
together after the truck
wound up in her apartment it's all in
there
most of it's destroyed you know it's
just
i've got the only change of clothes on
and they got a couple of pair of pants
out of there today and a blouse
francine mchugh is taking it one day at
a time
after she almost lost her life this past
saturday when a white pickup truck
rammed into her apartment
tonight we have the security footage of
when the incident occurred
while it's still unclear what happened
somehow the truck lost control
and ended up in the front of francine's
living room we're just
extremely happy that francine wasn't
hurt today her neighbors and friends
rallied around her to help her get some
of her belongings
out of the disheveled apartment a
non-profit even stepped in to help
this was a tragic experience for her and
many others in this community
i know francine i've sat in that
apartment and i've sat
at that window they were able to find
her keys debit cards
purse and other personal things so what
we did today is we're able to
help her by going into the unit and
retrieving some of her personal items
they opened the door and only let so
many people in
got it all out here then we got it on
the pickup and took some of it to
storage
but it was just like clothing no
furniture
they did get my old wheelchair out now
even though francine was able to
retrieve some of her items there's still
a lot
she knows she will need down the road as
for the person hit by the speeding truck
his condition is still unknown but he
was seen sitting up when the ambulance
arrived
and if you would like to help out
francine a gofundme page has been
created to help with her essential needs
and we'll have a link
up on our website reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now